deutschland geht in den shutdown das
öffentliche leben wird ab mittwoch
massiv heruntergefahren um die
explodierenden corona zahlen wieder in
den griff zu bekommen mitten in der
weihnachtszeit
das alles hat natürlich auswirkungen auf
die feiertage das wissen wir
aber wir sind zum handeln gezwungen und
handeln jetzt auch die nachrichten des
tages heute mit barbara hahlweg
ein folgenreicher dritter advent guten
abend und willkommen zu den heute
-nachrichten norbert lehmann ist auch
dabei für den sport beim bummel
versammlungsverbot an silvester strenge
kontakt beschränkungen auch über
weihnachten im kampf gegen korona legen
bund und länder das öffentliche leben
weitgehend still
ab mittwoch bis mindestens zehnter
januar große teile des handels müssen
schließen
kinder und erwachsene wenn möglich zu
hause bleiben
anton kurschilgen mit den wichtigsten
neuen regeln die läden werden ab
mittwoch geschlossen offen bleiben nur
geschäfte für den täglichen bedarf dazu
gehören unter anderem supermärkte
apotheken drogerien tankstellen banken
und postfilialen dienstleister wie
friseur kosmetik und massage salons
müssen schließen
medizinisch notwendige behandlungen wie
physiotherapien sind aber weiter möglich
auch schulen und kitas werden ab
mittwoch geschlossen es soll eine
notfallbetreuung geben
schüler werden digital zu hause
unterrichtet eltern sollen bezahlten
urlaub nehmen können um ihre kinder zu
betreuen
weihnachten darf man höchstens vier
angehörige aus dem engsten familienkreis
zu sich nach hause einladen plus kinder
bis 14 jahre die anzahl der ausstände
spiel zwischen dem 24 und 26
dezember keine rolle silvester gelten
die normalen kontakt beschränkungen also
fünf personen aus maximal zwei
haushalten plus kinder bis 14 jahren
außerdem wird der verkauf von böllern
und pyrotechnik verboten feuerwerk soll
dieses jahr ausfallen und ab mittwoch
ist auch alkoholkonsum im öffentlichen
raum verboten was ist erlaubt und was
nicht alle maßnahmen finden sie unter
zdf heute.de und in unserer app bund und
länder hatten sich diesmal sehr schnell
geeinigt auf ein gemeinsames vorgehen in
dieser zitat katastrophe andreas köhlers
berichtet so schnell so einig und so
besorgt waren die kanzlerin und die
ministerpräsidenten noch nie streit kann
sich deutschland nicht mehr leisten und
keinen tag verzögerung corona sei außer
kontrolle geraten die todeszahlen
alarmierend wieder all den stecken
familien menschen die auch gerne
weihnachten silvester lebt hätten die
kliniken echt sind die echtzeit derzeit
unter der belastung teilweise gibt es
schon trias in deutschland anders als im
frühjahr hält die politik diesmal ihre
schutzmaßnahmen für gerichtsfest
ich glaube hier auch angesichts der zahl
der toten angesichts des exponentiellen
anstieg in dem wir wieder sind sind
diese maßnahmen so erkennbar notwendig
dass ich da nicht mit großen
schwierigkeiten rechnen mit weiteren nie
dagewesenen überbrückungshilfen will der
finanzminister die betroffenen branchen
unterstützen kosten pro monat 11
milliarden euro
ich halte sie für absolut richtig denn
es geht hier um existenzen es geht um
männer und frauen die über viele jahre
und jahrzehnte sich ein geschäft
aufgebaut haben und jetzt sorge haben
dass in wenigen wochen und monaten eine
ganze lebensleistung verschwindet am
mittag ruft merkel die chefs der
bundestagsfraktionen an grundsätzliche
ablehnung kommt nur von der afd
wir haben eine klare linie wir sagen wir
können nicht ohne strategie immer wieder
dieses land dicht machen
wir vernichten existenzen und das
möchten wir nicht wir haben als
wichtigstes gut die akzeptanz bei den
bürgerinnen und bürgern die darf nicht
weiter zurückgehen sondern ich wünsche
mir dass sie steigt
weil manche landtage noch abstimmen
müssen bleiben die geschäfte noch bis
übermorgen offen es soll keine einladung
sein das ziel muss sein bei den
verordnungen die wir jetzt beschließen
nicht wieder das schlupfloch zu suchen
vielleicht kann auch jeder persönlich
sogar mehr machen als in der verordnung
drin steht die verordnungen gelten erst
mal bis zum 10
januar am fünften wollen bund und länder
beraten wie es danach weitergeht
theo koll in berlin mindestens bis zum
zehnten januar gelten die verordnung
aber möglicherweise ja noch sehr viel
länger
ja denn der zehnte januar ist schlicht
der letzte sonntag innerhalb der vom
infektionsschutzgesetz vorgeschriebenen
obergrenzen für maßnahmen für länger als
vier wochen dürfen einschränkungen erst
einmal nicht beschlossen werden aber es
gibt schon jetzt berechnungen dass in
einigen bundesländern trotz harter
maßnahmen das ziel von nur 50
infektionen und damit der kontakt nach
verfolgung nicht bis zum 10
januar zu erreichen ist und dem rest von
deutschland auch nur eine lockerung an
weihnachten auch deshalb will man wohl
anfang januar die lage neu bewerten und
wenn nötig den shutdown möglicherweise
dann verlängern
ein shutdown ausgerechnet in der
umsatzstärksten zeit des jahres wie
genau wie die bundesregierung den
geschäftsleuten helfen
erneut wird eine großen finanziellen
anstrengungen der bundesfinanzminister
sprach heute von über 11 milliarden euro
kosten pro monat
es soll zuschüsse zu den fixkosten geben
höhere monatliche hilfen bis maximal
eine halbe million euro für betroffene
firmen der wertverlust von waren die
jetzt nicht mehr verkauft werden können
soll durch teil abschreibungen
abgemildert werden also den
wirtschaftlich betroffenen soll
weiterhin geholfen werden das heißt aber
auch der berg an kroner kosten der
steigt weiter dankeschön für diese
einschätzung aus berlin von theo koll
der handel schlägt allerdings schon
alarm die vorgesehenen hilfen würden
nicht ausreichen um eine pleitewelle in
den innenstädten zu verhindern
und auch sonst löst dieser shutdown
mitten in der vorweihnachtszeit
gemischte reaktionen aus david sauer hat
die details
hüttenzauber damit lockt monheim am
rhein zum verkaufsoffenen sonntag es
gibt gebasteltes gewürze geschenke
solange es noch geht vorher besorgt aber
wie die leute halt leid die einfach hat
dann die umsätze hat nicht haben aber da
sind ja persönlich geschickt also was
nicht existenzen wie da dranhängen liebe
leute noch gar keine geschenke gekauft
viele haben auch die möglichkeit gar
nicht online zu bestellen weil sie keine
kreditkarte in den fußgängerzonen endet
das weihnachtsgeschäft am mittwoch
vorzeitig die umsätze sind weg aber die
miete läuft weiter das ist auch die
hoffnung im bereich bildung deshalb nur
noch notfallbetreuung und wenn möglich
lernen von zu hause
darauf sind viele schulen nicht
eingestellt es ist ein harter einschnitt
auf den sich kitas schulen und natürlich
auch die eltern vorbereiten müssen wir
erwarten wir verlangen dass die
regierungen jetzt die schulen in die
lage versetzen sich auf die zeit nach
den ferien gründlich vorzubereiten
vorbereitungszeit gab es eigentlich
reichlich ein dreiviertel jahr nach
beginn der pandemie
doch auch wenn manche die entbehrungen
langsam satt haben werden nun noch
einmal alle kräfte gebraucht
insofern ist es ganz wichtig dass man
die bevölkerung mit einbezieht dass man
sie eben mit nimmt es ist letztendlich
eine ja eine notbremse die jetzt
notwendig ist aber sicherlich keine
nachhaltige strategien eine notbremse
soll die gefahr so schnell wie möglich
abwenden
und wie zügig das nun zum jahresende
gelingt werden die zahlen erst mit
verzögerung zeigen am wochenende
übermitteln nicht alle gesundheitsämter
neue daten trotzdem sind auch die korona
zahlen von heute weiter hoch das robert
koch institut meldet 20.200 neue
infektionen innerhalb von 24 stunden das
sind 2433 mehr als vergangenen sonntag
321 menschen starben an oder mit dem
virus mehr zur corona lage gleich nach
dieser sendung im zdf spezial
deutschland vor dem shutdown anderes
wichtiges thema der streit um den braig
cit eigentlich sollte heute die letzte
chance sein für eine einigung nun gehen
die verhandlungen zwischen eu und
großbritannien aber doch weiter um doch
noch ein handelsabkommen zustande zu
bringen
darauf einigten sich eu kommissionschef
in von der leyen und der britische
premier johnson bei einem
telefongespräch
hauptstreitpunkte waren zuletzt vor
allem regeln für einen fairen wettbewerb
und der zugang von fischern aus der eu
zu britischen gewässern
da fragen wir nach in brüssel und london
zunächst zu stefan leifert nach brüssel
am 31 12 stefan läuft die übergangsphase
ab selbst wenn jetzt noch eine einigung
klappen sollte ist es dann überhaupt
noch rechtzeitig umsetzbar
also unter missachtung sämtlicher regeln
und gepflogenheiten wäre es durchaus
noch möglich ein brett city sowohl durch
europa parlament als auch durch
britische unterhaus zu bringen die
europa parlamentarier haben sich vor
langer zeit schon den 28 12 im kalender
markiert als tag einer möglichen
abstimmung nur dort braut sich etwas
zusammen in den letzten tagen ist der
unmut über diesen zeitplan massiv
gestiegen immer mehr abgeordnete sind
nicht mehr bereit in allerletzter
sekunde ein brett city jetzt mit der
brechstange durchs parlament zu
peitschen der normalerweise sind drei
monate zeit um handelsverträge dieser
größe zu übersetzen juristisch zu prüfen
und dann zur abstimmung zu stellen
in diesem fall sollen mal eben 700
seiten so viel so viel seiten würde ein
möglicher braig city umfassend mal eben
geprüft und dann zur abstimmung gestellt
werden und dass in ein paar
weihnachtstagen also da braut sich etwas
zusammen wo sie davon
ansonsten wissen dass haben sich heute
dazu verabredet jetzt auf täglicher
basis miteinander zu kommunizieren nur
die zeit arbeitet jetzt gegen sie und
möglicherweise bald auch das
europaparlament die zeit diana
zimmermann in london was bedeutet diese
hängepartie für die britischen
unternehmen ja selbst die coolsten
unternehmen werden hier jetzt wirklich
nervös vor der einzigen wirklichen
deadline in 18 tagen niemand weiß wie
der handel ab erster erster laufen soll
und so gab es schon in der vergangenen
woche massive staus um dover herum
einfach weil alle versuchen noch
möglichst viele waren aus dem land
heraus und ins land hinein zu bringen
trotzdem wird hier mit
versorgungsengpässen gerechnet boris
johnson hat ja heute gesagt das land sei
auf einen deal vorbereitet das sieht
unter anderem so aus dass lebensmittel
ketten gesagt wurde sie sollten für
sechs wochen vorräte anlegen
allerdings momentan hier im winter ist
es so dass 90 prozent der tomaten und
des salats aus der eu kommen
es ist also kaum möglich da für vorräte
anzulegen die unternehmen letzten jetzt
wirklich nach einer entscheidung aber
wenn man sie fragen würde wollte er
lieber heute
oder dann doch nächste woche einen deal
wie dünger auch sein mag dann würden
sich wohl die allermeisten immer für den
deal entscheiden
dankeschön nach london und brüssel
stefan leifert und diana zimmermann in
nach polen sind regierungsgegner zu
neuen protesten auf die straße gegangen
die demonstranten zogen von der
warschauer innenstadt zum haus des
mächtigen konservativen parteiführers
kaczynski die polizei riegelte die
straße ab seit der verschärfung des
abtreibungsrechts im oktober kommt es in
polen immer wieder zu protesten zurück
nach deutschland weihnachten und
silvester das sind reisetermine für
millionen normalerweise aber normal ist
wenig zurzeit das bekommt auch die bahn
zu spüren spitzeneinnahmen zur jahresend
saison daraus wird wohl nichts fahren
müssen die züge aber trotzdem dritte ist
fahrplanwechsel über die bahn im corona
modus hans jürgen thiel
fahrscheine werden teurer um ein prozent
erhöht die bahn die preise im
fernverkehr lässt dafür aber auch mehr
züge fahren ab heute zwischen hamburg
und berlin etwa jede halbe stunde ein 60
statt 46 tägliche verbindungen der
halbstundentakt zwischen berlin und
hamburg ist schon ein vorgeschmack auf
das was uns in einigen jahren erwartet
in deutschland nämlich der deutschland
pakt ein durchgängig verpacktes system
von fern und nahverkehrszügen bis hin zu
biss anschlüssen eine bessere
erreichbarkeit und vor allem sehr leicht
merkbare abfahrtszeiten für das ganze
netz ist das aber noch zukunftsmusik
aktuell gilt ab heute normalpreis
tickets werden teurer spartickets und
bahncard 50 und 25 aber nicht neben dem
neuen halbstundentakt soll es zwischen
bonn und berlin aber auch von münchen
nach zürich mehr verbindungen geben
zu weihnachten waren diesmal doppelt so
viele sonderzüge wie im letzten jahr
wohl pandemie bedingt weit weniger
reisende erwartet werden kritik vom bund
der steuerzahler
die menschen nutzen die bahn nicht mehr
so wie vor der krise und deswegen ist es
widersinnig dass die bahn genau jetzt
noch mehr waggons auf die gleise bringt
ich glaube man muss sich entscheiden
entweder man fährt nachhaltig und
effizient ein programm oder man macht
das was man jetzt macht und dazu braucht
man noch mehr und massive steuergelder
doch die idee bleibt dabei das
wichtigste sei jetzt dass fahrgäste
genug platz haben um ausreichenden
abstand zueinander einhalten zu können
jetzt die sport nachricht des tages
norbert der bvb trennt sich von trainer
lippi nach der peinlichen 1 zu 5
schlappe gegen aufsteiger stuttgart
gestern nachmittag war dann doch wohl
des schlechten zu viel
fabres bisheriger assistent edin terzic
übernimmt das team und soll die
mannschaft bis zum saisonende trainieren
das nachmittagstraining heute wird schon
von edin terzic geleitet kurz zuvor gab
der club die trennung von favre
offiziell bekannt keine 24 stunden nach
der pleite gegen den vfb
wir alle sind lucien favre dankbar für
seine hervorragende arbeit in den
vergangenen zweieinhalb jahren in denen
er mit seinem team zwei
vizemeisterschaften errungen hat als
fachmann und als mensch ist lucien favre
über jeden zweifel erhaben 3 liga
heimniederlagen in folge waren jetzt zu
viel auch wenn favre selbst weiter
optimistisch war
ich finde es sehr schade dass sich
unsere wege trennen wir haben eine
mannschaft die auch in diesem jahr am
ende eine erfolgreiche saison gespielt
hätte davon bin ich nach wie vor
überzeugt diesen nachweis müssen jetzt
die mannschaft und der neue trainer
erbringen und im ersten sonntagsspiel
der bundesliga trennten sich augsburg
und schalke 2 2 die königsblauen waren
dem ersten saisonsieg sehr nah der
ausgleich fiel kurz vor schluss
überschattet wurde die partie von der
kopfverletzung des schalkers mark huth
der nach minutenlanger behandlung auf
dem spielfeld mit einer schweren
gehirnerschütterung ins krankenhaus
gebracht werden musste zur skiflug wm in
planica gestern deutschland im einzel
ganz knapp vor norwegen heute beim
teamspringen was genau umgekehrt vor dem
letzten durchgang das deutsche team noch
komfortabel in führung dann der super
sprung von halberg nadelöhr bei
verkürztem anlauf weltmeister karl
geiger konnte nicht kontern und norwegen
verteidigte seinen titel
max verstappen hat das letzte formel 1
rennen der saison gewonnen in abu dhabi
der niederländer siegte vor den beiden
mercedes piloten valtteri bottas und
weltmeister lewis hamilton sebastian
vettel der enttäuschte erneut er landete
ohne punkte auf platz 14 war sein
letzter auftritt für ferrari nächstes
jahr fährt er dann im neuen team von
aston martin bietet das wetter bringt
zumindest für einige ein paar
lichtblicke morgen im nordwesten dichte
wolken und zeitweise regen sonst nach
nebelauflösung etwas mehr sonne vor
allem richtung alpenvorland vier bis
zwölf grad
das was von uns danke für ihr interesse
morgen übernimmt hier wieder christian
sievers ich wünsche ihnen trotz allem
einen guten start in die neue woche